[MUSIC PLAYING]
HENRY GREEN:
Splenvid is a new way
to relive and share your life
through automated content.
JEFF RAUBITSCHEK: A lot of
computer vision algorithms
have been applied to
different problems,
but this is basically
taking these algorithms that
have existed for a while and
bringing them to consumers
and making it help
their curation process.
So we've built on top
of open source tools,
but are really
leveraging those tools
to figure out how
to use that metadata
to create the best
movie as possible.
Or you might actually find that
we didn't do the perfect job,
and you can go in and
tweak it and customize it
for exactly what
you're looking for.
And then, on the
technology side,
we actually take that
feedback and make sure
that the movies that we
create for you the next time
are going to be better and more
customized to what you like.